Until now, what we have seen in this lecture is a quick review of the concepts
that you are most likely already familiar with. The next lesson will launch into
the evolution of the operating system's structure.
Before we get into that lesson, if you
feel you could benefit from reviewing the basic
concepts of an operating system. I strongly recommend
that you review the basic subsystems of an operating system. CPU
scheduling, memory management and the network protocol stack. To help you
navigate this background material, my tall friend here, Charlie Brubaker has
produced lecture materials that are available as part of this course offering.